i have to point out you and your sweet
life co-star brenda song you had babies
within a month of each other maddie can
be your new tutor
what there isn't enough money in the
world
i'll pay you triple your salary
apparently there is enough
what goes through your mind when you
think about how you were
kids together acting on the same show
and now you both have kids
that is crazy um it is so
weird uh i feel like it just shows what
stage of life we're in
i guess i don't talk to her anymore but
she um i think is like
obviously killing it as a new mom as
well are you and brenda still on good
terms is everything cool
yeah i mean i think it's just like
obviously like you go and you do
different things you know like obviously
i've i've gone on to do different shows
and she's gone on to do
different shows so it's just like
sometimes you just haven't spoken to
someone in a long time but yeah i know
she's the sweetest and
so great and i'm just so happy for her
and it's just awesome
it is really nice though i have like a
lot of friends that had babies like
literally my girlfriend hilary had a
baby the day after me and then also my
friend kim had a baby the day after me
and it's just so crazy because i can
literally count 10 people
that are like my friends that have
babies it's
been a wild time this year your daughter
jupiter she's about four months old now
yeah wow i mean what has motherhood felt
like
oh man i mean it's like so weird it's
funny because when she's sleeping i like
look at pictures of her i'm just
obsessed and i will look at chris and be
like we have a baby
because it's just so wild um
it's amazing i mean obviously everyone
always says this and you just don't
really understand it until you have it
baby but
i feel like it's just like life is more
meaningful and
she's just such a little great addition
to the family amazing i mean you use the
word wild
i'm curious what is the wildest moment
that you've experienced with jupiter
since she's been born going to the beach
for the first time would be wild
what happened i was so excited we
brought a tent
because obviously we're like you know we
brought her little kind of baby beyond
like bouncer so she asked me to sit in
and so we got this tent
however we didn't factor in like the
wind and so
it was a pretty windy day and this tent
was
falling over and i broke like two nails
because i was just like oh my gosh like
just trying to like
handle everything and it's like this
isn't just like a relaxing beach day
you just like lay on the beach and get
some sun and this was like
a full panic of like oh bro this is
falling over
and trying to like you know make sure
she's okay and
now we bring like you know just so much
stuff with us
it's just like a whole different
experience so that to me was probably i
was like
i think maybe let's like not go to the
beach for a while
to kind of i don't know maybe walk or
something
yeah well look moms are superheroes you
gotta dive in there you gotta lose a
nail a few times in order to make sure
that everything's okay with your baby
yeah is there a milestone that she's hit
or something that she's done
that you and maybe your husband just
like lost it over how cute it was
she's constantly hitting you know
milestones i feel like
at her tummy time she's like one of
those champion tummy timers where
she can go like 20 minutes i remember
the first time she went to go grab
something
and i'm like oh my god she like grabbed
her little like rattle and i was like
that's
insane i'm so proud of you grabbing
something
but the same thing like i saw her like
sucking her thumb the other day and i
was like
that's so new i thought that was so cute
we're here to talk about a topic that i
can absolutely get behind
iced caffeinated beverages tell me what
it is you're doing with jamba
well i love what you're saying you're
speaking my language
um you know obviously as a new mom i
just like
need to have a little bit of caffeine
and jamba came out with a
gacha matcha and it's so delicious it's
so good and it's also got this like
sweet cloud
whip foam topper that is insanely
amazing and actually made in-house
i'm dairy free so it's just been one of
those things that i like
love that they're doing more plant-based
options so i became a big fan of it
and so they have been become part of my
day with becoming a mom i'm sure your
your morning routine has shifted
somewhat how what what is a morning
in the french household like now that
you've got this matcha fueling you
you've got a cute little baby with you
yeah i mean obviously it's completely
changed
from what it used to be but it's like
obviously changed so much for the better
jupiter's amazing she's so so great we
have her sleeping 12 hours now so she's
killing it
we got her sleep trained and she's been
amazing you know obviously i'm staying
home a lot right now so it just like
it's also really nice just against car
and drive to jamba and be able to get
you know the gotcha matcha
and a bolding cold brew for my husband
it's just a one-stop shop
and it just makes me like obviously be
prepared for the rest of the day
because you don't realize i mean i did a
lot obviously in the past
i could fit in a lot in my day but with
a baby
i think it's just like obviously like
it's a little bit more exhausting
it's like definitely like you're it's a
lot going on and then she has her like
calendar of stuff to do so i'm just like
this is you know
now she's got activities and i'm ready
to take a nap when she's ready to take a
nap at this point